joe rogan threatens to sue cnn for
defamation on their claims that he was
taking horse dewormer well not exactly
he was just simply grousing about what
he claimed was unfair reporting by jim
acosta claiming that joe rogan had taken
horse dewormer it is in fact true that
joe rogan took ivermectin after he
contracted covid19 but he got a
prescription from his doctor and took
the human variation of the drug that
doesn't actually look like he's gonna
sue but let's assume that he was would
he have a case for defamation well
probably not first of all as a celebrity
to have a very hard time against acosta
and cnn because he'd be subject to the
actual malice standard which requires
basically that jim acosta know that what
he was saying was false on top that
acosta might have the defense of
substantial truth because ivermectin in
variations is used for both horses and
people and then of course there is the
defense of hyperbole and opinion your
opinion on revealed facts because acosta
was intending to insult rogan because
rogan like an idiot refused to get
vaccinated so he had to get treatment
after the fact for his covet infection
so is it sloppy reporting yes is it
defamatory no are we going to see these
people in court sadly not